da sich fortsetzung folgt
[Musik]
elefanten auf ihrem weg zur arbeit
und genau das ist faszinierend
sie empfehlen wurden beide tore kurz
frischknecht und bert wieso sie entsteht
dann ein lichtblick in der kulisse vom
circus knie was es alles braucht bis das
programm mit stadt und diesen zirkus
sind sauber kann entwickeln und auf die
schönste moment von dem film passiva
wirkung rätsel aber zurück jeder tag
beginnt für die elefanten mit einem
fitnessprogramm in der probe manege von
knies kinderzoo in rapperswil franco
knie senior hat heute unterstützung als
einenkel chris rui
er ist knapp zweijährig und wird dieses
jahr zum ersten mal in der manege
auftreten
franco junior ist der vater des kleinen
seit fast 100 jahren arbeitet die
familie knie mit elefanten langsam soja
banane für dieses kunststück brauchen
großvater franco und mutter lina
absolutes vertrauen in den elefanten
ich bin mit elefanten aufgewachsen ich
dann anders wenn man der hund sich an
elefanten mit humax ganz natürlich muss
nicht vergessen und elefant bleibt
zwischen 50 und 60 jahre also sich nicht
nur dass man zusammen ist klar dass
ganzes leben für mich ganz ganz wichtige
zahl
das war nicht von meinem vater gleich
und twitter haben so dass ich die
zusammen aber das ist aus mich
begeistern mit einer tier sheridan knie
und ihr siebenjähriger sohn ivan sind
gekommen um sich die elefanten schoren
zu schauen
geraldine gehört zu jener linie der
familie knie die traditionell mit
pferden arbeitet bald wird yvonne mit
dem zirkus auf tournee gehen
geraldine sieht das positiv aus eigener
erfahrung
nach der saison aufgehört hat da hab ich
mir fast doch noch viel magie immer
zirkus funktionsreiche und im wohnwagen
ist das für mich
[Musik]
schläger schön gerade jetzt im
kindergarten sich alles mega-show franco
knie senior ist der technische direktor
und leitet den zirkus zusammen mit
seinem cousin fredy knie
dem vater von geraldine eine nummer zum
schmunzeln elefantendame dehling legt
sich nur mit einem kopfkissen hin
[Applaus]
der kleine chris können die vier turner
noch nicht so recht einschätzen
vater sohn und enkel drei knie
generationen in aktion
wer die knie der artistische direktor
des zirkus ist mit seinem enkel ban in
paris
im renommierten circa die wr villa einen
weltklasse artisten treffen
freddy ist in der ganzen welt unterwegs
um neue zirkuskünstler kennenzulernen
[Musik]
heute geht es um mario peru sieg seine
chancen zu einem höhepunkt im knie
programm 2008 werden
[Applaus]
innsbruck unterwegs und ich glaube nur
schnell wo also mario ja nichts
überlassen will nicht weiter kann sie
nur noch von schiffbauern wird auf der
tournee gesellschaft bekommen mario hat
drei töchter
[Gelächter]
die mädchen kommen mit ibahn in die
schule
auf der tournee wird eine lehrerin in
einem schul wagen unterrichten
[Musik]
ceylon ist bei franco knie junior in der
pediküre
[Musik]
es ist ein intensiver bezirk spieltag
der mannschaft vermittelt dir und euch
dann auch jetzt sage was man verlangen
er weiß was ich da machen und weise tun
nicht weh aber zugeben dass ich die
vorläufe bekommen
[Musik]
dieses loch den stadien können wir das
leben sich nachmittags die zeichnungen
waren teil und hinten hier kommen so
stehe jetzt auch geraldine knie macht
sich bereit für die probe ihr sohn ivan
kommt vom kindergarten und schaut hier
bei der arbeit zu
sie ist im zirkus geboren und trainiert
seit klein auf mit ihrem vater fredy
knie mit vier jahren trat sie zum ersten
mal in der manege auf und wurde zur
nationalen zirkusprinzessin der vater
von fredy knie hat die pferdedressur
weiter entwickelt und geprägt weit über
die landesgrenzen hinaus
diese pionierarbeit für freddy zusammen
mit seiner tochter geraldine weiter sie
trainieren die nummer ungarische post am
ende galoppieren 10 araberhengste vor
saladin was wie eine imaginäre
postkutsche aussieht aber ich kreiere
charakter und das ist aber schon
numérique der dort sehr wichtig in drei
wochen ist premiere
die artisten treffen aus aller welt ein
der guinness buch rekordhalter mario
bewusst ist aus paris angereist
ja
in der manege wird nun pausenlos geprobt
[Musik]
das ist die erste nummer die geraldine
mit ihrem lebenspartner michael yani
aufführt
[Musik]
fredy knie ist bei den proben stets
dabei
[Musik]
der italiener michael yani ist ein
preisgekrönter spitzen akrobat auf dem
pferd wirkt er noch nicht so routiniert
wie seine partnerin
[Musik]
wow
was fehlt eigentlich morgens mit jetzt
noch aber sei es dann zum beispiel
naja wenn zum wichtigen das hat es nicht
gerade musiklehrer sich eigentlich nur
so viel wer al deen stimmt die musik für
ihre tango nummer noch nicht es fehlten
die magie und die emotionen nach dem
marsch dauert es zu lange bis es losgeht
[Musik]
kgaa merck und so diskutieren sie bis
weit in den abend hinein tag der
premiere bei der familie franco knie
wird es eine doppelte premiere geben
der kleine chris bekommt sein erstes
kostüm wenigsten nervös waren
ja es ist bewegt mich sehr und ich sehe
dass es weitergeht und vor allem dass
man elefantenbaby hand wo schon mit dem
vater geschaffen mit mir mit dem sohn
und hitze normaler generation wie das
ist ein risiko chris kann noch nicht
einmal sprechen würde aber bald im
sägemehl stehen und kompliment machen
in seinem niegelnagelneuen kostüm
wieder bei rapperswil vierzehnter märz
2008 die zirkus saison beginnt
[Musik]
gleich ist es soweit die artisten
konzentrieren sich
[Musik]
vorhang auf
geraldine auf den schwarzen hengsten die
nummer die sie und ihr vater freddy
wochenlang geprobt haben
geraldine ist enttäuscht doch das
publikum unterstützt sie mit kräftigem
applaus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenige augenblicke später steht sie
wieder auf dem rücken ihrer pferde
[Musik]
die ungarische post wird trotz des
sturzes zu einem erfolg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit professionellem lächeln mit
geraldine den beifall entgegen
[Applaus]
doch hinter dem roten vorhang sieht man
wie ihr wirklich zumute ist ihr
lebenspartner michael tröstet sie auch
ihr vater freddy und sohn ivan muntern
sie aus es war das tier das sich nicht
konzentriert hat genau aber nachricht
vielleicht nehmen wir ein anderes werden
bald sind die elefanten daran franco
knie junior hat ein problem
der schneider hatte nadeln im stau
stecken lassen
50 jahre besteht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mario buseck beweist einmal mehr dass er
der schnellste jongleur der welt ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der allererste auftritt des jüngsten
spross begleitet vom stolzen großvater
[Applaus]
kompliment
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die grauen vierter verdecken den 13 kilo
leichten buben aber hier ist in diesem
programm trotzdem der allergrößte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das große finale
standing ovations
[Applaus]
immer auch virtuell selbst
[Musik]
die zellen konstrukt ihren beifall und
schon bald cc mit zelt und wagen quer
durch die ganze schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wieder stehen oder am gleichen platz
wie wiesenhof gehört profil bereitet
sich zu etwas familie kniefall neue
saison so wie immer aber immerhin
gewisse kollegen merken schnell da hat
sich einiges verändert
märz fällt wird erst mal die iss
aufgestellt es ist wie ein
familientreffen
die meisten der 100 mitarbeiter reisen
alle jahre wieder empfangen werden von
franco knie junior und forscherin knie
für beide ist es ein besonderer
saisonstart als neue generation
übernehmen sie jetzt zwei davon für die
neue saison ist das verdient ein
schmetterling und kling schlaflose nacht
besorgt aber der umfrage vor der
emotionen
das kann manchmal richtig schlafzimmer
mit der maßnahme und ferien morgen im
wohnwagen stand man landläufig wieder
herunter guckt ist eigentlich
géraldine knie ich jetzt die
atheistische direktor in unterfranken
junior der technische direktor moment
für die fotos wieder los
aber jetzt du wieviel verantwortlich
dass sie kaum ist vorbereitet und vom
technischer direktor hatte franco wo
sein vater ein franco knie senior und
auch lieder schafft für die elefanten
folgen gehabt
es ist die zweite saison wurde vater
franco microsoft ohne hund
die nummer ist nur vor dem vater der
elefant buch erzähle wird gewünscht
[Musik]
das klappte nicht so ganz
und da ist der chris rui person von
franco und vor der lena knie
was liegt für die physiker jahr zum
ersten mal in der manege gestanden ist
der kreis trainiert wenn immer
rechenzentren elefantenfamilie und
akrobatik klasse der schule wo im
zirkuswagen mitfahrt eine schule nur
ganz kurz klappt das immer so guter in
dieser probe ja ja bist du bist auf dem
elefanten gestanden wie es sie schon
einmal heruntergefahren hat saft sicher
ist es schwierig auf einem elefanten zu
stellen dass papa streng im training mit
dir so kommen ist immer
weil manchmal muss ich auch zur schule
anders als kritisch sind vater frank und
im zirkus aufgewachsen
nach der scheidung von seinen älteren
xavi der mur taxi und vor allem in den
ferien vater im zirkus franco hat
informatik erklärt mit einer 20 statt
eindruck zum zirkus knie ist mir im
kreißsaal für pflichten und wochen
selbst also mach jetzt geändert so wie
es ist die füße erwartet haben also dass
sich ja nicht zwingen wenn doch ins
gegenteil user sieht keine tasse sind
hier geboren und ich mache keinen spaß
und sie mir nur durch den zentralen dass
gott einer dem es für die schule hatte
sich das wichtige und ansonsten blieb
das heißt du vor dieben und die ganze
region hervor sein vater gehabt und von
den anwendern die relevanten unterschied
zu vista zu machen
der vortrag ist anders
sie muss sich endlich die macht der
familienunternehmer für das neue dritte
es geht nur als unbekannt mitglied von
der zirkusfamilie wohl eher im
hintergrund blieb doris kliehm musiker
büro waage ist für alles administrative
zuständig sie ist schwester von franco
junior und zieht das baujahr zurück ins
geschäft
das ist schon mit 2 3 in der manege
gestanden geboren
ältere hat sich daimler scheider und
dann sehen wir einfach wieder ferien im
das heißt ist ein zyklisches familie wo
sein er erwarte dass sie überhaupt nicht
aber ich liebe das leben auf tournee
geboren berichtet wird findet ja ja aber
das da auf cd nur noch in kleinen
verschlag auf noch größere manege
ich fühle mich sehr gut gewöhnliche
dinge wie immer um das hat alles
ausgebucht und wenn wir ein klima zum
ehrenbürger wünschte büro aber mich
gemeint ist sagte rinner
treffpunkt ist hier ja
amen von tag stolz zählt ab sofort
manege
bis zur premiere vor zwei wochen
gerald in knie verbringt praktisch der
ganze tag in der manege
sie bespricht mit allen artisten die
einzelnen um das licht und musik
[Musik]
ihr programm vor dem jahr laut ferrari
fährt dann zu ihren ehemann michael
branik und natürlich ihren vater der
fredy knie stellen ihre zusammenarbeit
ist nach wie vor eine erhebliche
verkehre überhaupt ist jeder pause
machen wir sind die neue generation wo
jetzt verantwortung übernehmen
hast du jetzt anders und ohne ihn als
dass du das noch bei 7 8 hosen und ihr
vater sich wurde christa leichtigkeit
winters generation erwachsen ich finde
ich eher zurück wie sie es wollten wir
sind das familienunternehmen und
deswegen nicht ausgraben oder so
entscheiden
irgendwo muss ja oder nein das beschert
doch schon als vater schon immer sehr
also wie sagt man dem ja großzügig sie
mit mir und hat mich immer rauer
entscheidung live mini vinci gegangen
also vor dem herrlich wie man gewalt
also das ist schon so harmlos leyen muss
jetzt los ich lila salons laut also dass
im auf keinen fall ich wirklich wird er
erzählte prämiert wird loslassen würde
man sagen er ist älter firma da lag sie
für mich und ich ihn liegt auch noch
immer da für mich
wo feiert zins ist fredy knie nicht weg
ein schwieriges los dann sagen schafft
also für mich überhaupt nicht schwierig
sich und das sage ich jetzt einfacher so
das ist für mich einfach toll dass ich
ermittle aber ich bin da sie wissen
sicherlich jeder sicher folge ich gebe
mal machen ruft aber ich sage ich mache
sich auf besuch merkt was er dir aber
machen was welt und dann entweder sie
lassen das muss es so und ich bin
natürlich präsent wie es herzig mit dem
pferd das macht sich jede und jeden
morgen im training da könnte auch nicht
dass ich sie will dass ein gut machen
aber das darf einfach nicht mehr
pferde tresor steht für tradition im
zirkus knie aber konkurrenz im
unterhaltungsmarkt grad auf oder
digitale welt ist massiv grösser wird
das ist unser fordere für die nächste
generation wir fest muss sich der zirkus
der moderne zeiten anpassen dass andere
sich immer sehen viele zirkustiere ich
ganz klar höchstens noch tradition und
tradition aber wenn wir genau wann er
nur können damit gezielt optimiert und
ist auf andere und traditionelle zirkus
machen heißt die verstaubte zirkus
machen
das heißt einfach hatte eine
traditionelle element festhalte und die
aber den modernisierer und moderner
verpackte präsentieren
[Musik]
das credo von fredy knie setzte den
unter michael wieder manege nun
[Musik]
die haben
bonnie
michael ist eigentlich ein spitzen
acrobat reader letzten sieben jahre hat
in der friedrich knie im moment werde
zurich führt jetzt präsentierte michael
eine schwierig stadt werden um reine
zirkus geschichte sein
[Musik]
die pferde hast du in der manege wenn du
das haus selber 28 große und das erste
mal und meine frau in die türe
meine frage ist ein fremdkörper ist
während der probe planig 1 kurz vor der
premiere der franco hat mit seinen
elefanten klebt
stellen sie verlernen kann das hat sich
sehr aufmerksam und ja es wird so sein
dass andere mal wo sie nicht erzählt man
schlecht sich in den ballon hat oder was
der aktion die junge generation und
intuition kurs der generation
playstation generation youtube seite
zurückgenommen
playstation und dadurch die sich aus
virtuell und 48 schon alles live und
ungeschnitten und achten spiel
der imam knie das sohn von gérard den
hut für einen kurzen moment sind ich
probte vergesse
da war müsste jetzt schon auf dem pferd
barati und großvater franz letzte mal
gesehen ist er im kinsky xxi jetzt ist
er im siebten schuljahr und lernt von
dem großvater grad die hohe schule vom
ressort it
[Musik]
hallo du bist jetzt deine freunde die
machen jetzt schnupperlehren oder gehen
ins gymnasium entscheiden sich für einen
beruf hast du dich schon entschieden
ja ich mach mal hier weiter also für
mich ist jetzt einfach circus circus
circus
im moment sehe ich nichts anders hoffe
dass es so weitergeht
hast du manchmal auch keinen bock ja das
kommt logischerweise vor vielleicht
einen tag lang hat man ist man müde oder
so das hat aber jeder war meistens wenig
arbeiten und ich bin auch lieber so ich
habe es nie beim zirkus zu sein dass
jetzt im camping zu sitzen und einfach
nichts machen klar einmal in der woche
ist das mal schön aufzulegen oder
fernsehen zu schauen aber doch am
liebsten wenn ich schnell
[Musik]
sie rief sie und die manege kursbremse
die journalist tochter von geraldine und
von michael
[Musik]
und sie war es schon ziemlich genau was
sie will ihren regt macht nun mit musik
[Musik]
haben wir nicht jedes lied einzeln zum
einspielen sonst warten wir den ganzen
tag morgen haben wir das orchester die
schulter aber nicht zu viel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kni dünner stehe hätten zirkusprinzessin
andere länder für abschied bei franco
knie senior ist nur mit dem zirkus
unterwegs
ich führe der neue welt der letzten
jahre der neuen elefantenpark in knies
kinderzoo aufbaut wird die heutigen
zirkusshow im moment großes thema wird
wahnsinnig diskutiert viele europäische
staaten verboten oder sehr stark
eingeschränkt
ich folgte die diskussion bedruckten
freundin
ja ich glaube was ganz ganz wichtig ist
sprich was mit elefanten macht ccc
physisch oder oder dauernd so wichtig
ist dass er beschäftigt ist und sich
wohlfühlt klares kritiker wird es immer
geben
das ist so es kommt immer darauf an was
für kritik dass ich oder wenn das kritik
von fachleuten oder von tierschützern
tierschützer sehen du nicht aktivisten
wo man wirklich über das problem verrät
er wo auf die tiere bis verstehen
da kann man mit und lösungen suchen das
haben wir auch immer für sie für
dieselbe ich setz dich zweite saison so
losgeht
ohne die ich was wir das für mich dass
ich meine stellte die und vorstellig see
und der besteuerung zu verlieren ist
natürlich klar dass bei mir aber dann
gleichzeitig bin ich stolz wenn ich
jungen gesehen der mann ist da und wie
es weitergeht aber für immer vertrauen
da wo natürlich kommen nicht jetzt ist
es soweit 26 märz premiere in rapperswil
[Gelächter]
also das wünschen wir müssen also
beinbruch
sein
ok
es muss alles stimmen geraldine vieles
mit dem komponisten oder musik
ihren sohn der country ist auf dem weg
in die manege
[Applaus]
der ivd präsentiert mit sind wert die
traditionelle hohe schule interessierte
begleitet von modernen tanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja irgendwas sagen mama und mit russland
sind also bis jetzt ist noch ziemlich
gut
mal sehen was dann passiert sein das
musste ich aber wir haben es geschafft
ich bin sehr stolz auf meine kleinen
jungen und auch den großen haften
von nervosität keine spur
[Musik]
mit dem manager tritt nur als anderes
bekanntes gesicht auf der schnellste
jongleur von der welt der mario peru sac
ist druck und auch sie mal wieder mit
dem knie unterwegs
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im publikum doris knie
[Musik]
channel und ihres boni nach projekt sind
souverän und professionell wie die
großen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
chris rui vorsieht mit knapp 2 hat doch
unrecht keine steueroase und jetzt ist
reine für die jüngsten die lehrer von
der welt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt hat elefantendame delhi ihren
großen moment
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das große finale
im moment bereitet eine gans
verabschiedet
und standing ovations vom publikum
[Applaus]
die neuen siebte generation führt die
tradition wieder da die achte zirkus im
blut
fortsetzung folgt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
iris leben auf der alp wunde schmerzt
aber auch strengen supersexy zum verkauf
langhammer kesslers begleitet wie all
ihren hochs und tiefs finden
hier ist es wieder mit dem betrieb von
der bergbauernfamilie gisler
fortsetzung folgt in einer woche